yo you know [ __ ] Sebastian is a crab
and not a lobster did I know this he's a
crab did you know that in in this note
oh well they already announced I know Oh
does he not know he doesn't know so in
the in this ABC live musical Ursula is
Queen Latifah and Sebastian is Shaggy
[Laughter]
how they got him for that cuz he like
fell off the face of the earth for like
30 years and then whoever it was like
yeah shaggy would make a great Sebastian
what the [ __ ] yeah that's crazy
hmm so there you have it you would have
been a part of that casting this is
gonna be a multicultural [ __ ] Little
Mermaid it is the girl who got cast for
a Little Mermaid is the Moana chick how
do you say her name I don't know the
because there was that whole controversy
with the whole the the the whatsit
what's her name I actually don't know
but where's she from
she's pretty well-known right because
people know who she is you her and her
sister
yeah they they had a cover on YouTube
that I believe somehow made it to the
hands of Beyonce and then like Beyonce
shouted them out I don't know they just
like blew up and went viral and now then
they had like a really successful
YouTube musician career mm-hmm and then
like they even sang at the Grammys last
year I think what
yeah they got invited to sing at the
Grammys last year no yeah and now this
girl is well one of the sisters which I
always wonder like when it's like a duo
like that like does your sister feel
jaded like tell you something man I find
a brother and then we were the singing
duo and then he went off to be [ __ ] I
don't know shang-chi the music are you
trying to say you're jealous or senior
huh are you trying to say you're jealous
I don't think anybody's jealousy
just kidding he's a nice guy we were we
were we were on JK news together I would
have loved to seen a shang-chi with you
dog I would have made the best funniest
Shane she ever did for my [ __ ]
superhero powers I would be to stir-fry
anything stupid
I'm pretty sure there was a lot of like
Asian actors going for that [ __ ] yeah
that Shane she [ __ ] yeah I knew a lot
actually personally when people they
were asking me they were like yo aren't
you hiked about shang-chi I'm like who
the [ __ ] is that dude [ __ ] shang-chi is
I was mispronouncing it the whole time I
was calling a Shang chai you know who
the [ __ ] she was well Somchai sounds
more Asian than string cheese it does hi
it's got a chance oh yeah I guess so
you're right like did you know what did
any [ __ ] person out there in the
[ __ ] podcast will know who shank she
was I definitely didn't nobody knows who
the [ __ ] shank she is right so like when
people are like are you hyped about it
no I'm not hyped about it I don't
[ __ ] know who shank she is if I grew
up with shang-chi I'd be [ __ ] hype as
hell
we are you saw auditioning every now and
then if I want to DG audition for change
I would crack the [ __ ] up I would have
loved to have seen that I would have
loved to audition for that [ __ ] cuz I
would have done it with a thick ass time
juice but you're also how well your
fight training so why not well I'm not
camera fight training though I'm fight
fight training though that's different
oh you're trying to like beat some
people up in real no no no I just do boy
type of Moutai stuff isn't made for
camera so it's like it's completely
different right when when yo she comes
in and trains with us he has to get rid
of all of his camera [ __ ] and be more
practical fighting so it's a little
different yeah cuz when that stuck in my
eye like people are asking me to be
hyped about it I can't be because I
don't know who it is
was there ever a superhero you ever
wanted to play Oh of course man I want
to I want to yeah [ __ ] The Blob
[ __ ] he's a villain I love that
[ __ ] no I don't really care for that
country you know you don't care for
superhero stuff I like I don't know I
like comic books and stuff but I don't
have a urge to want to play one you know
what I mean like I don't have a
connection to it like that but I love
superhero should I grew up with like
Marvel like the whole DC Universe and
everything like that but
like I talked about this before where
I've never had this idea where you know
when people ask me do you wish that
there would be more Asian superheroes
well for me as a kid when I saw
superheroes I never thought that my
ethnicity was a barrier for me to try to
emulate a fake character you know I
never looked at supermen descent all
because you know I'm a Cody in a man I
can't be Superman
I'm just like no I'll be Superman like
what the [ __ ] does that matter also - I
grew up in a very diverse area so there
wasn't a lot of white people in my
school so nobody was gonna say otherwise
yeah I didn't really grow up with a lot
of that that type of prejudice that
other people did cuz Sacramento is just
extremely close to a diverse so I don't
I don't know what that feels like
right cuz I feel like for you did you go
brown a lot white people yes but I also
my high school is pretty divert like I
was one of four Asian people in my high
school but that being said I think I had
a bit of a weird utopian environment of
high school where I never got called out
for being Asian like nobody made me feel
like the token Asian ever yeah so it
wasn't it wasn't this thing to make of
it I just was like I would my identities
were oh she's the smart one who's also
the dancer and is in choir like those
were mine Denny's not like asian chick
that's why it's hard for me to relate to
that time yeah right so it's like man I
know that a lot of people who kind of
grew up in that like I can't really
speak for them yeah I know like this is
one kid when I was in UCR what CeCe are
you University of Riverside right
shoutouts to this I said it like I it
like yeah I know you see our baby [ __ ]
you that school sucks but they yeah this
kid was telling me about how when he
grew up like I'm talking about in San
Diego like he grew up in San Diego and
he went to like an all-white school and
like kids used to bully him make all
these Asian jokes at him like threw him
in a bush and [ __ ] like that and I did
not grow up with that so I don't even
know what the [ __ ] that shit's like man
I can't imagine like a white guy coming
up to me and going oh yeah and I'll be
like all right like I mean there's it
would just be so odd I wouldn't even be
a Fed that it would just be like whoa
what's this guy doing yeah actually
don't think I like really got any
ching-chong remarks until I got to
college in New York City of all places
like that's where I really felt like I
was told me you graduated from NYU did
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy I didn't know
that you told me you don't know anything
about me
okay where did I graduate from [ __ ] how